Schönen guten Tag, mein Name ist Ujak. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das eine Mösegespräch durchführen.
Damit sind Sie ein Verstanden?
Ja, ich bin ein Verstanden, Doktor.
Danke. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Florian Krone.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
Florian Krone.
Und mein Nachname ist Krone.
Frau Krone oder Herr Krone?
Frau Krone.
Frau Krone, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 45 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
7. Juni 1980.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter, 87.
Und wie groß sind Sie zurzeit?
Ich bin 57 Kilogramm.
Okay. Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Meine Hausärztin ist Frau Schmidt.
Danke für die Informationen. Frau Krone, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zurzeit?
Ich bin heute hier, weil ich seit gestern Nachmittag starke Schmerzen im linken Sprunggelenk habe.
Frau Krone, können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Also sind sie eher drückend, stechend, brennend?
Steckend und brennend.
Weiter.
Und strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwohin aus?
Nein. Immer diese Beschwerden im Sprunggelenk.
Okay. Also sind diese Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Nein. Immer dauerhaft.
Frau Krone, sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Plötzlich aufgetreten, ja.
Okay. Haben Sie sich Ihr Sprunggelenk verletzt?
Ja, ja. Das Ganze ist passiert, als ich mit unserem Hund im Wald unterwegs war, Doktor.
Plötzlich musste ich dem Hund hinterlaufen und bin dabei über einen losen Stein gestoppt.
Dabei bin ich mit dem linken Fuß nach innen ungeknickt.
Sind Sie verstanden?
Ja.
Ja, okay.
Alles klar.
Ja.
Okay. Frau Krone, wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
Ja, ich würde den Schmerz mit 8 von 10 der Skala beschreiben, Doktor.
Okay. Und haben Sie dagegen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe 15 mg Ibuprofen eingenommen, aber es hat mir nicht geholfen, Doktor.
Okay. Soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmitte geben oder können Sie diese Schmerzen noch ein bisschen bis Ende des Sprechs aushalten?
Es wäre besser, wenn Sie mir eine Schmerzmitte geben, Doktor.
Okay. Haben Sie Allergie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ja, ich habe Novaginalergie, Doktor.
Okay. Und leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen wie zum Beispiel Nierenversagen?
Ich habe keine, nein.
Okay. Alles klar.
Schwester Müller, bitte geben Sie den Patienten eine Schmerzmitte.
Okay. Wir haben Ihnen eine Schmerzmitte verabreicht. Frau Krone, fühlen Sie sich besser?
Ja, ich fühle mich besser, Doktor. Bis dahin, aber nicht ganz besser.
Okay. Alles klar. Darf ich das an einem Nasegespräch weitermachen?
Okay. Ja, natürlich.
Okay. Frau Krone, haben Sie in diesem Bereich, ich meine linkseitige Sprunggelenk, eine offene Wunde oder Blut bemerkt?
Ich habe keine offene Wunde, aber seitdem ist der Fuß angezwollen, Doktor. Und Blut verparrt und fühle sich taub an, ja.
Haupreizgefühl haben Sie richtig?
Ja, ja, ja.
Und haben Sie auch Kribben?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay. Und haben Sie Überwerbung in diesem Bereich bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Nur Schwellungen und Perkos?
Ja.
Okay. Alles klar. Frau Krone, wann war Ihre letzte Tetanus-Impfung? Erinnern Sie sich?
Ich habe nicht erinnert, aber ich denke, es war sehr lange, ungefähr 10 Jahre oder 12 Jahre.
Okay. Alles klar. Alles klar. Okay. Ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, Doktor. Ein bisschen. Aber ich bin nicht einmal übel, ja.
Okay. Und mussten Sie erbrechen?
Nein, ich habe keine Erbrechen, ja.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, darf ich fragen?
Nach dem gestern habe ich keinen Appetit.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen?
Ja, ja. Ich denke wegen dieser Schmerzen, ja.
Okay. Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit unwirklich ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt. Ich bin immer gleichgegeben.
Okay. Und haben Sie Fieber, Schüterfrost oder Nachtschweiz?
Ich habe keine dieser Schwerden, nein.
Das freut mich. Ist alles in Ordnung beim Wasserlassen und mit dem Stuhlgang?
Wasserlassen, Stuhlgang? Ja, ich habe keine Probleme.
Okay. Frau Krone, haben Sie bei diesem Unfall Ihr Kopf verletzt?
Nein, Doktor. Ich habe immer mein Spruchgelenk verletzt, nein.
Okay. Leiden Sie unter Luftnot oder Brustschmerzen oder Husten?
Ich habe keine dieser Schwerden, nein.
Das freut mich. Okay. Und schlafen Sie gut?
Nach gestern schlafe ich nicht gut, Doktor. Wegen dieser Schmerzen, nein.
Ja. Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Beide. Beides, okay. Alles klar.
Und sind Sie schon vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Ja, ja. Ich bin vollständig geimpft, ja.
Okay, alles klar.
Frau Krone, leiten Sie an chronische Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bruthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe seit etwa drei Jahren Gischt. Und außerdem vor drei Wochen hatte ich auch einen akuten Gischtanfall, ja.
Welches Gelenk meinen Sie?
Linke.
Also Spruchgelenk oder Ellenbogen oder Handgelenk?
Spruchgelenk.
Linke Seite, Spruchgelenk, ja?
Okay. Und was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ich nehme Allopyrinol 300 mg morgens.
Sonst?
Und bei Bedarf überprofen sind 800 mg bei Bedarf.
Okay. Und haben Sie irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Ja, vor fünf Jahren hatte ich einen Bandscheibenverfall im Lenden-Wilde-Bereich, noch einen Motorradunfall.
Das wurde konservativ mit Physiotherapie behandelt, ja. Aber ich habe immer noch Schmerzen, Doktor.
Ich verstehe. Und nehmen Sie auch Ibuprofen dagegen ein?
Ja, bei Bedarf, ja.
Das war es oder?
Nein, außerdem leide ich seit fünf Jahren an Geistamtsyndrom, ja.
Geistamtsyndrom, ja.
Und was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Mit Durchfallen und Blasen.
Welches Medikament nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ich nehme Imodium, bei Bedarf.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Ich erinnere nicht, nein.
Okay, kein Problem. Ich werde Ihren Hausärztin kontaktieren, ja?
Ja, danke schön.
Gerne. Das war es oder?
Nein, ich habe viele klinische Erkrankungen.
Ja, ich verstehe. Bitte schön.
Vor 15 Jahren wurde bei mir das Stimmbandknochen festgestellt.
Deshalb bekomme ich eine Lapardistiktherapie.
Und regelmäßig Neuangehen plus Lusttabletten.
Alle drei bis vier Stunden.
Okay, Sie nehmen Neuangehen, Lusttabletten.
Ja, ja.
Alle drei bis vier Stunden.
Sie haben auch etwas gesagt, aber ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Gegenstimmbandknochen?
Ja, festgestellt.
Deshalb bekomme ich eine Logopädische Therapie.
Okay, Logopädie.
Therapie, okay, alles klar.
Ja, sonst?
Ja, ich habe auch gesagt, ich habe eine Schlafstörung.
Ja, okay. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Operiert worden? Ja, wegen starker Fettleberigkeit hatte ich eine Magenverkleinerung.
Wann war das? Vor fünf Jahren.
Okay, und alles in Ordnung? Ja, ja, jetzt alles in Ordnung.
Okay, und war das OP komplikationslos verlaufen? Ja, komplett.
Alles klar, gut, das freut mich. Und sonst?
Vor sechs Jahren wurde ich außerdem an rechten Knie wegen einer Schlimmbautenentzündung operiert.
Leibautentzündung, okay, das war es, ja? Ja, ja.
Okay, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf andere Medikamente ein, außer genannten?
Nein.
Frau Krone, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine neue Allergie haben und wie äußert sich diese Allergie?
Mit Atemnot Doktor.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche anderen Allergien?
Ja, ich habe eine Lattex Allergie.
Ja, wie äußert sich diese Allergie?
Die Allergie äußert sich durch Hautrötungen.
Okay, haben Sie Unfertigkeit gegen irgendwelche Nahrungsmittel?
Ich habe, nein, keine Unfertigkeit, ja.
Frau Krone, rufen Sie?
Ich bin seit fünf Jahren nicht Raucher. Davor habe ich etwa 15 Jahre Schachtel und Zigaretten geraucht.
Okay, trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Alkohol trinke ich nur am Wochenende, etwa einen halben Liter Bier.
Okay, bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit 16 habe ich mal Haschisch und Methamphetamin ausprobiert, aber das ist lange.
Okay, momentan nehmen Sie keine Medikamente ein, ja?
Nein.
Leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, mein Vater hat Bluthochdruck und beide Seiten Granulast. Es wurde auch an den Augen operiert.
Meine Mutter hatte vor zwei und halben Monaten eine Brustkrebsoperation und bekommt derzeit Strahlentherapie.
Strahlentherapie?
Bei der Leben jetzt, ja.
Okay, diese Operation war vor sechs Monaten oder?
Zwei und halbe Monate.
Okay, Monate.
Ja.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine Brüder, meine Brüder hatten eine Maggenoperation oder Gewiss-Tradition, ja.
Okay, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin seit drei Jahren Gechehen, Doktor. Und wohne mit meinen Lebenspartnern zusammen.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe drei Kinder.
Sind diese Kinder gesund?
Eine davon hat eine Hörnminderung, ja. Hörminderung.
Okay, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite als Rechtsanwalt.
Okay, Frau Krone, das waren meine Fragen. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe starke Schmerzen. Was habe ich?
Ja, also Frau Krone, Sie hatten eine Verletzung am linken Sprunggelenk und deswegen werde ich Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Wir werden kontrollieren, ob Sie einen Bruch bei den Knochen haben oder Gewebeprobleme, wie zum Beispiel Bandriss.
Deswegen muss ich ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen. Sobald alle Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich mit Ihnen weitere Informationen mitteilen.
Wird Sie Röntgen untersuchen oder?
Ja, auf jeden Fall werden wir eine Röntgenuntersuchung machen, Frau Krone. Das ist sehr wichtig bei uns.
Ich habe von meinen Nachbarn gehört, dass Röntgenuntersuchungen gefährlich sind für unsere Körper, Doktor.
Wir werden nur eine geringe Röntgenuntersuchung geben, Frau Krone. Also kann es passieren, dass Sie momentan schwanger sind? Ich habe vergessen zu fragen.
Also machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen, Frau Krone.
Okay, danke schön. Bleibt Sie im Krankenhaus, Doktor?
Ja, also ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben. Aber wenn wir etwas Ausfälliges finden, kann es auch passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen, Frau Krone.
Okay, Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie. Danke schön.
Okay, sehr gerne. Ich bin wieder da, ja?
Okay.
Schönen guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ujak. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnesegespräch durchführen. Damit sind Sie einverstanden?
Ja, ich bin einverstanden, Doktor.
Danke. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, okay?
Ja, okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße F. Heinzmann.
IFA Heinzmann, ja.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vollnachnamen langsam beschtebieren?
IFA Heinzmann.
Ja.
KINZMANN.
Doppel N, ja?
Ja, Doppel N, ja.
Okay. Frau Heinzmann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 39 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
4. Mai 1996.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,83 Meter.
Und wie schwer sind Sie zuzeit?
70 Kilo.
Okay. Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Herr Kratz.
Okay. Frau Heinzmann, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie zuzeit?
Ich habe Schmerzen, Doktor.
Wo genau haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ich habe Schmerzen in den Finger- und Zehengelenken.
Beide Seiten.
Okay. Also meinen Sie Zehe und andere Fingergelenke?
Ja, ja.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Seit etwa 4 Wochen habe ich diese Schmerzen.
Okay. Frau Heinzmann, könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher drückend oder stechend oder brennend?
Ich habe auch Schmerzen.
Und drückend und brennend, ja.
Sind diese Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Nicht dauerhaft. Manchmal dauerhaft, manchmal gehen Sie wieder weg, Doktor.
Als Wellenformigen?
Ja, Wellenformigen. Sie haben Recht.
Okay. Strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, nein. Die Schmerzen strahlen nicht irgendwo hinaus.
Okay. Alles klar.
Frau Heinzmann, haben Sie die ähnlichen Beschwerden früher gehabt?
Ja, Doktor. Ich habe diese Probleme ungefähr seit 2 Jahren.
Und haben Sie wegen dieser Probleme einen anderen Arzt besucht?
Ich habe meinen Hausarzt gegangen, Fileman.
Und jetzt bin ich bei Ihnen.
Und welche Erkrankung wurde diagnostiziert?
Haben Ihre Hausarzt darüber etwas gesagt?
Mein Hausarzt hat mir gesagt, dass ich irgendwo irgendwelche Gelenkprobleme habe.
Aber wie es heißt, habe ich keine Ahnung.
Okay. Und nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, jetzt nehme ich kein Medikament ein.
Aber früher nehme ich bei Bedarf ein Neuallgintablett.
Und hat dieses Medikament Ihnen geholfen?
Es hat mir ein bisschen geholfen, ja.
Okay. Alles klar. Sie haben gesagt, dass diese Schmerzen beidseitig sind.
Haben Sie dieses Problem an irgendwelchen anderen Gelenken gehabt?
Ich meine Handgelenk oder Ellenbogen oder Kniegelenk?
Ja, letztes Jahr. Das war mein Handgelenk. Sie haben recht.
Und damals waren diese Probleme auch beidseitig, oder?
Ja, beidseitig.
Okay. Frau Heidsmann, leiden Sie unter Morgensteifigkeit auf diese Gelenke?
Ja, Doktor. Die Schmerzen sind morgens am schlimmsten.
Meine Gelenke sind dann geschwollen und steif.
Ja. Es wird aber besser, wenn ich mich bewege oder die betroffenen Stellen kühlen.
Okay. Und darf ich fragen, wie stark diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10?
Ungefähr 7, denke ich.
Okay. Alles klar. Und Sie haben gesagt, dass die Bewegung und die Kühlung verbessern sich diese Schmerzen?
Ja, ja.
Sie haben starke Schmerzen am Morgen, auch Ödeme, also Gelenken?
Richtig, ja. Besonders morgen.
Okay, alles klar. Frau Heidsmann, haben Sie noch irgendwelche andere Beschwerden bemerkt?
Ich meine Kopfschmerzen, Seh- und Hörstörungen?
Ich habe keine bemerkt. Aber ich habe seit den Schmerzen auch Schlagstörungen. Ich schlafe schlecht, Doktor.
Aber außerdem habe ich weniger Apertit seit etwa 3 bis 4 Wochen und deswegen auch 2 bis 3 Kilo abgenommen.
In welchem Zeitraum?
Etwa 4 Wochen, ja.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Ich habe beides, ja.
Okay. Haben Sie Fieber, Schüttelfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Fieber, Schüttelfrost, Nachtschweiß habe ich nicht.
Okay. Und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Ich habe keine Probleme mit Wasserlassen oder mit Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen, nein.
Okay. Frau Heinzmann, haben Sie an Ihren Gelenken, ich meine besonders Finger, eine Deformation, ich meine Sie ein Strukturproblem bemerkt?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, Doktor, nein.
Okay, das freut mich. Und bleiben Sie unter Husten oder Luftnot?
Ich habe keine Luftnot und Husten, nein.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Corona-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft, Doktor, ja.
Okay. Frau Heinzmann, besuchen Sie Ihren Frauenarzt regelmäßig?
Ja, ich gehe bei meinen Frauenarzten regelmäßig drei Monate, Doktor.
Wann war Ihr letzter Besuch?
Vor zwei Jahren, vier Monate, ich würde sagen.
Vor zwei Monaten. Und alles in Ordnung?
Ja, alles in Ordnung, ja.
Okay. Wann war Ihre letzte Monatblutung?
Vor zwei Wochen, ja, Doktor.
Okay. Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, an chronischen Beschwerden habe ich seit vier Jahren Sod brennen, ja.
Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, dagegen ich täglich Omeprosol 40 Milligramm einnehme, ja.
Morgens oder abends?
Morgens.
Okay, sonst?
Außerdem habe ich eine Skolioze seit meiner Jugend, aber die wurde nie behandelt.
Okay. Sie nehmen kein Medikament ein, ja?
Ja.
Okay. Und sonst?
Doktor, ich habe vergessen Ihnen zu sagen, ich habe jetzt keine Probleme mit Stürgang.
Aber wenn ich Stress habe, bekomme ich Durchfall, ja.
Okay. Und nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, ich werde gerne noch dagegen behandelt, aber jetzt erinnere mich nicht.
BS heißt Doktor.
Ein Medikament oder?
Ja, ein Medikament.
Okay, alles klar. Kein Problem. Also ich werde Ihren Hausarzt kontaktieren für diese Details, ja?
Okay. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Operiert worden? Ich habe nicht operiert worden, nein.
Okay. Und nehmen Sie irgendwelche andere Medikamente außer Gelände?
Ja, nein.
Okay. Frau Heinzmann, haben Sie Allergie gegen irgendwelche Medikamente oder Pflanzen oder Nahrungsmittel?
Ja, ich habe eine Allergie gegen Ciprofloxas, Doktor.
Und wie ausstattet sich diese Allergie?
Ich hatte damals einen Hautausschlag und eine Bindehautentzündung. Davon bekommen, Doktor.
Sie haben an Bindehautentzündung gelitten, deswegen haben Sie Ciprofloxas eingenommen, richtig?
Ja, ja.
Okay. Bindehautentzündung, ja? Okay.
Ja.
Sonst haben Sie irgendwelche anderen Allergien?
Ich habe Allergie gegen keine anderen Medikamente oder Nahrungsmittel, Doktor.
Okay, das freut mich. Frau Heinzmann, rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich bin Raucher, Doktor, leider.
Seit wann und wie viel rauchen Sie?
Ungefähr 10 bis 15 Zigaretten am Tag. Seit etwa 20 Jahren, Doktor.
Okay. Also, Frau Heinzmann, wenn Sie möchten, können wir Sie dabei unterstützen?
Wir haben ein gutes Programm im Krankenhaus, mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören oder mindestens das Rauchen zu reduzieren, ja?
Ich freue mich sehr, Doktor, wenn Sie mir helfen können, Doktor.
Ja, sehr gerne. Also, nach dem Aufnahmegespräch können wir darüber sprechen, okay?
Okay, okay. Danke.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Alkoholtrinken, ja, natürlich. Alkoholtrinken ist nur gelegentlich. Vielleicht ein bis zwei Gläser Wein.
Also, was meinen Sie pro Woche, gelegentlich pro Monat?
Ja, am Wochenende oder treffen mit meinen Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Okay.
Oder einen Verein, ja.
Okay, also.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Zwei Wochen oder, ja, ich weiß nicht, ja, jetzt.
Okay, alles klar. Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Kontakt mit Drogen? Nein.
Okay, das freut mich, Frau Heinzmann. Leiden Ihre Eltern noch, Frau Heinzmann?
Entschuldigung, bitte?
Leiden Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, ja, ja. Beides.
Leben, Entschuldigung, ja. Leiden Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, ja, meine Eltern leben jetzt, ja.
Okay, und leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, mein Vater leidet an Bluthochdruck und meine Mutter leidet an Schlecht-Krankheit-Doktor.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Okay, wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe drei Kinder. Entschuldigung.
Und sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, alle sind gesund, ja.
Okay, wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Ja, ja, ich wohne mit meiner Frau und meinen Kindern, ja.
Okay, was sind Sie von der Ruf?
Ich bin Handwerker.
Was machen Sie eigentlich, Frau Heinzmann, was meinen Sie damit mit Handwerken?
In einer Fabrik oder?
Ja, ich arbeite in einer Fabrik, ja.
Okay, sind Sie zufrieden bei der Arbeit?
Nein, ich habe ein Problem, Doktor.
Es war sehr nicht einfach für mich, in dieser Fabrik zu arbeiten.
Ich verstehe, Sie haben recht. Okay.
Aber wie gesagt, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen, Frau Heinzmann.
Also Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen.
Sie sind ja jetzt im Krankenhaus und wir werden alles für Sie tun, okay?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Können Sie mir eine Krankheit schreiben, Doktor?
Ja, also Frau Heinzmann, zuerst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Und dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Was ist Blut abnehmen?
Wir werden Ihnen Blut abnehmen für Labors, Frau Heinzmann.
Das ist sehr wichtig bei uns.
Wir werden einige Werte kontrollieren.
Ich vermute, dass Sie eine Rheuma haben.
Deswegen werde ich Ihnen auch Blut abnehmen.
Und auch werde ich ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Wie zum Beispiel Röntgen-Untersuchung.
Ja, Doktor, Rheuma ist sehr gefährlich.
Ich habe gehört, ich muss arbeiten.
Ich habe drei Kinder, eine Frau.
Frau Heinzmann, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Also mit einer guten Therapie werden Sie wieder gesund sein.
Diese Krankheit ist keine lebensbedrohliche Krankheit.
Wir werden die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen.
Und dann werden wir Medikamentöter-Therapie anordnen.
Und Sie werden sich besser fühlen.
Funktioniert die Medikamentöter-Therapie für mich?
Ja, wir haben gute Therapiemöglichkeiten.
Diese Therapien funktionieren sehr gut bei unseren Patienten.
Also machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Sie werden wieder gesund und Sie werden wieder in dieser Fabrik arbeiten.
Ich habe von einer Seite gelesen.
Es gibt viele Nebenwirkungen mit den Rheuma-Medikamenten.
Ist das richtig oder falsch?
Frau Heinzmann, wir werden ein paar Medikamente anordnen.
Aber gegen diese Nebenwirkungen werden wir auch andere Medikamente geben.
Also machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Und wir werden Sie regelmäßig kontrollieren, ob Sie ein Problem haben.
Ja, ich danke schön. Ich warte auf Sie.
Sehr gerne. Bitte nehmen Sie einen Platz.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Schönen guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne über Sie berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön.
Frau Florin Krone ist 45 Jahre alt, 1,87 Meter groß und 57 Kilogramm schwer.
Frau Krone stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit gestern Nachmittag bestehender,
plötzlich aufgetretener linzseitiger Sprunggelenk Schmerzen zustand nach einem Sturz vor.
Der Patientin zufolge habe sie im Wand mit ihrem Hund unterwegs und plötzlich habe sie auf einem losen Stein gestoppert
und mit dem linken Sprunggelenk nach innen umgeknickt.
Die Schmerzen würden nirgendwo hin ausfallen.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf einer Schmerzkala mit 8 von 10 bewertet und die Einnahme von 500 Milligramm Ibuprofen hätte keine Linderung der Schmerzen gebracht.
Die Patientin berichtete über Ödem, Hämatome und Hypostäse am Sprunggelenk und die Fragen nach Blutungen, offener Hunde, Parastäse, Kopfverletzung,
Brustschmerzen, Trusses und Dyspnoe wurden verneint.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folienden bekannt.
Nausea ohne Emesis, schmerzbedingte Inappetenz und schmerzbedingte Insomnie in Form von Ein- und Durchschlafstörungen.
Sie sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft und letzte Tetanusimpfung war vor 12 Jahren.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte sie seit 3 Jahren bestehende Arthritis Ulrica und vor 3 Wochen Diagnostizierte Giftattacke im linken Sprunggelenk, also Podogra.
Vor 5 Jahren Diagnostizierte Diskus prolaps in ländlichen Wirbelbereich bei Motorradunfall und seitdem chronische Lumbargie.
Seit 5 Jahren bestehende Reiz-Darm-Syndrom und vor 15 Jahren Diagnostizierte chronische Laryngitis wegen Stimmbandknochen.
Vor 5 Wochen, ich habe die Fachbegriffe eigentlich vergessen, Herr Oberarzt, und die Patienten nehmen Alloprinol 300 mg morgens und Ibuprofen 800 mg bei Bedarf gegen Arthritis Ulrica ein.
Chronische Lumbargie wurde konservativ mit einer Physiotherapie behandelt und sie nehme gegen Diarrhe und Meteorismus im Modium Tabletten bei Bedarf ein.
Und sie nehme neu angehende Lutsch Tabletten alle 3-4 Stunden ein. Gegen Laryngitis.
Vor 5 Jahren sei bei ihr eine Magenverkleinerung durchgeführt worden und vor 6 Jahren sei sie wegen einer
Schleimbeutelentzündung, also Bursitis, im rechten Knie operiert worden. Sie habe Allergie gegen Novalgin, die sich durch Dyspnoe äußert und sie habe auch Latexallergie, die sich durch Erythem äußert.
Sie sei Ex-Raucherin seit 5 Jahren. Davor habe sie 10 Grad täglich 15 Jahre lang geraucht. Sie trinke eine halbe Liter Bier am Wochenende und sie habe mit 16 Jahren einmal Haschisch und mit Amphetamin probiert.
In der Familienanamnese gab sie an, dass der Vater an Arterhypertonie und beidseitiger Katarakt leide und die Mutter leide an Mammakalzinom, die vor 2 und halb Monaten
operiert worden sei und auch mit der Strahlentherapie behandelt wurde. Sie habe einen Bruder, der eine Magenoperation hatte, eine Gewichtsregion.
Eine Reduktionoperation. Sie sei geschieden seit 3 Jahren. Sie haben 3 Kinder und sie lebe mit ihrem Lebenspartner. Sie sei Rechtsanwalt von Beruf.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Sprünggelenk-Torsion aus, da die Patientin typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Die Patientin hatte ihr linksseitiger Sprünggelenk verletzt, beim Innenumknicken und sie leidet unter Oedema, Hämatome, Hypesthesie und starkem Schmerzen.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Torsion, Distortion. Als Differenzdiagnosen kommen Bänderriptue oder Bänderis im Sprünggelenk in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst bei der Patientin die Vitalparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob dem Hämatome Blutungen, offene Wunden, Überwärmung vorhanden sind.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose zu gewährleisten. Dabei würde ich Blutbild, CAP, BSG, Blutgruppe, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Elektrolyten bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich zwei Ebenen Röntgenuntersuchung durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien genau zu beurteilen.
Gegebenenfalls würde ich eine MRT verlassen, um die weiche Gewebe, Pathologien zu überprüfen.
Um die Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich die Patientin stationär aufnehmen. Ich würde die Patientin einen venösen Zugang legen und Analgetika, Antiemetika verabreichen.
Danach würde ich ein orthopädisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie der Patientin zu optimieren.
Bei der Therapie würde ich auch Hochlagerung des Beines, Kühlung, Fixierung durchführen, um die Therapie zu optimieren. Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise verstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Herr Kollege, ist es möglich als Differenzialdiagnose eine Tibiafibrofraktur oder Thalusfraktur?
Ja, die Patientin hat nach innen ungeknickt, deswegen können wir am Tibia eine Fraktur feststellen.
Was führen Sie zuerst, wenn der Patient eine Tibiafibrofraktur hat? Welche Diagnostikmaßnahmen führen Sie durch?
Zuerst würde ich die Patientin körperlich untersuchen. Ich würde unsichere und unsichere Frakturzeichen überprüfen.
Also eine Krepitation oder eine Deformation würde ich zuerst kontrollieren.
Und dann würde ich eine zweiebene Röntgenuntersuchung bei der Patientin durchführen, um die Fraktur genau festzustellen.
Können wir mit Hilfe der Zonographie eine Fraktur feststellen?
Ich denke, ja, nicht einfach, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ja, können wir mit Hilfe der Zonographie eine Fraktur feststellen, aber es braucht viel Erfahrung.
Wenn Sie im Röntgen des Schuprungengelenk keine Fraktur feststellen, aber führen Sie eine Fraktur, welche Diagnostikmaßnahmen führen Sie durch?
Wir können eine CT des Schuprungengelenk durchführen, um die Fraktur genau festzustellen.
Aber wenn Sie im CT des Schuprungengelenk keine Fraktur sehen, welche andere Diagnostikmaßnahmen zeigen uns Fraktur?
Fraktur, meinen Sie am Knochen? Ja, ja, Knochen.
Also, ich würde eine MRT für die weiche Gewählepathologie beurteilen, aber eine Fraktur, keine Ahnung, nicht mehr.
Manchmal Zonographie zeigt uns Fraktur auch.
Herr Kollegen, wenn der Patient nach Hause geht, was empfiehlt Sie dem Patienten?
Ja, also wenn wir diese Fraktur mit einer ...
Nein, nur Schuprungengelenkdistorsion denken Sie, nicht Differential Diagnose, Verdacht Diagnose speicheln.
Ja, also ein paar Tage würde ich ein Gipsverband benutzen, um das Schuprungengelenk zu fixieren.
Und also Kühlung, Schonung, Hochlagerung sind sehr wichtig bei dieser Situation.
Empfehlen Sie, früher zu laufen?
Nein, also ich würde ein paar Tage empfehlen, den Patienten ein paar Tage nicht zu bewegen.
Deswegen würde ich auch eine Antitrombosetherapie, würde ich sagen.
Ja, ich denke ich.
Können Sie zu uns CT aufklären?
Ja gerne, ich werde, Herr Oberst, ich werde Sie über CT aufklären.
Die Antomographie gehört zu den bildgebenden Verfahren.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, Verletzungen, Entzündungen, Blutungen, Tumore und andere Veränderungen genau zu erkennen.
Diese Untersuchung benötigt nur noch eine geringe Strahlenbelastung und ist völlig märzfrei.
Der Patient soll etwa 30 Minuten ruhig in einer CT-Röhre liegen und wenn der Patient eine Platzangst hat, können wir dem Patienten ein Beruhigungsmittel geben.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. 30 Minuten und manchmal sollen wir ein Schmerzmittel, ein Kontrastmittel geben, um die Organe sichtbar zu machen.
Es gibt einige Kontrast-Indikationen wie z.B. Schwangerschaft oder Kontrastmittelallergien und es gibt keine Komplikationen.
Nach der Untersuchung gibt es keine Anschränkungen und der Patient kann den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Hat diese Untersuchung Strahlung?
Meinen Sie CT?
Ja.
Benötigen wir eine Strahlung oder? Meinen Sie Herr Oberarzt? Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Während der Untersuchung geben wir den Patienten Strahlung?
Ja, wir geben eine geringe Strahlung.
Was bedeutet diese geringe Strahlung? Gefährlich oder verursacht Tumoren?
Nein, eine geringe Strahlung geben wir den Patienten. Wenn die Patienten schwanger sind, ist das gefährlich. Aber sonst ist die Menge Strahlung gering.
Wenn der Patient schwanger ist, was empfehlen Sie den Patienten?
Wir können eine MIT durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien zu beurteilen.
Vielen Dank, Herr Kollege. Gehen Sie weiter zu weiter Falle?
Ja, ok. Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt. Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über Sie berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Vielen Dank. Frau Eva Heinzmann ist 39 Jahre alt, 1,83 Meter groß und 70 Kilogramm schwer.
Frau Heinzmann stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit vier Wochen bestehender
Finger- und Zehgelenke Schmerzen vor.
Bei der der Patienten zufolge seien diese Schmerzen drückend, brennend und wellenförmig.
Die Schmerzen haben mit der Zeit immer schlimmer geworden. Die Schmerzen würden nirgendwo ausstrahlen.
Die Patienten berichteten, dass sie ähnliche Beschwerden vor zwei Jahren hatten.
Werde Ihre Ausstrahlungsdessen wiederholen?
Die Schmerzen würden nirgendwo ausstrahlen.
Die Patienten berichteten, dass sie seit zwei Jahren diese Schmerzen leiden.
Momentan haben sie gegen diese Schmerzen keine Medikamente eingenommen.
Früher haben sie gegen diese Schmerzen Novalgin Tabletten eingenommen.
Die Einnehmer von Novalgin brachten eine weniger Linderung der Schmerzen.
Sie erwähnten, dass die Schmerzen immer symmetrisch seien.
Sie berichteten über die Steifigkeit an den Gelenken.
Sie berichteten, dass sich die Schmerzen bei der Bewegung und Kühlung verbessern.
Wie lange dauert die Steifigkeit?
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf eine Schmerzkala mit 7 von 10 bewertet.
Die Fragen nach Kopfschmerzen wurden verneint.
Sie haben die Frage nach.
Die folgenden Anamnese sind bekannt.
Schmerzbedingte Insomnie.
Seit 3-4 Wochen bestehende Inapetenz.
Gewichtsabnahme von 2-3 kg innerhalb von 4 Wochen.
Seit 3-4 Wochen bestehende Diarrhea.
Wegen Stress.
Sie wurden vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft.
Sie besuchten ihren Frauenarzt regelmäßig.
Ihre letzte Monatsblutung war vor 2 Wochen.
Sie hatte eine Anerkrankung.
Seit 4 Jahren bestehende Pirosis.
Seit Jugend bestehende Skoliose.
Sie nehmen 40 mg Omeprazole morgens ein.
Sie nehmen kein Medikament gegen Skoliose ein.
Sie wurde bisher noch nie operiert.
Sie hatte eine Allergie gegen Ciprofloxacin.
Sie hat sich durch Exanthem äußert.
Sie hatte eine Konjunktivität.
Deswegen hat sie Ciprofloxacin.
Sie wurde damals eine Allergie.
Sie war Raucher.
Sie rauchte seit 20 Jahren 10-15 Zigaretten täglich.
Sie trinke 1-2 Gläser Wein am Wochenende.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Sie hatte eine Anamnese.
Sie hatte eine Diabetes mellitus.
Der Vater hatte eine Arterie hypertonik.
Sie war Einzelkind.
Sie hatte 3 gesunde Kinder.
Sie wohnte mit ihrer Familie.
Sie war Handwerker in einer Fabrik.
Sie hatte Stress bei der Arbeit.
Sie hatte einen Verdacht auf eine Rheumatitis Arthritis.
Die Patienten hatten typische Symptome.
Sie leiden unter Gelenkschmerzen.
Sie hatten eine Morgenschleifigkeit.
Sie hatten ein Morgensdämme.
Diese Symptome sprachen für eine Rheuma.
Als Differenzierdiagnosen kamen Arthritis Ulrica,
Psoriathik Arthritis und Arthrose in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen,
überwache ich die Vita-Parameter der Patienten.
Ich mache eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf,
ob die Hautfarbe verändert wird.
Die Patienten haben eine Überwärmung.
Die Knoten an den Gelenken sind vorhanden.
Zusätzlich ist eine Labouruntersuchung sinnvoll,
um eine umfassende Diagnose zu gewährleisten.
Ich würde Blutbild, CAP, BSG,
Rheumatoid Faktor, CCP,
Leberwerte, Nierenwerte bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine Zweiebene Röntgenuntersuchung
den betroffenen Fuss,
bilaterale Zweiebene Fussgelenk oder Seegelenk,
bilaterale Zweiebene Fussgelenk Röntgen
durchführen, um die Pathologien zu beurteilen.
Wie z.B. Gelenkspaltverenkung oder Deformation bei dem Gelenk.
Ich würde eine CT-Mathematik durchführen,
um die möglichen Pathologien zu überprüfen.
CT oder MRT, welche Diagnosomasysteme führen Sie durch?
Ich würde einen MRT durchführen,
um die weiche Gewebepathologie zu beurteilen.
Oder wenn es eine sehr fortschrittene Gelenkverengung
oder andere Strukturprobleme bei den Gelenken gibt,
würde ich auch eine CT durchführen,
um die möglichen Pathologien zu beurteilen.
In diesem Fall Röntgen des Gelenks und MRT des Gelenks.
Das ist wichtig.
Ich habe schon die Zeit vergessen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen,
würde ich die Patientin stationär aufnehmen.
Ich würde einen Venosynzugang legen und Analgetika verabreichen.
Ich würde als medikamentische Therapie Methoterexat anordnen
und auch Foligsäure, um die Nebenwirkungen von Methoterexat zu vermeiden.
Danach würde ich ein rheumatologisches Konzil anfordern,
um die Therapie der Patienten zu optimieren.
Ich würde Lebensveränderungen geben,
wie zum Beispiel Rauchen, Aufhören,
Lebensstilveränderungen mit Nikotinkarenz.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vergehenweise einverstanden sind,
werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Führen Sie in diesem Fall Elektroneuromyografie durch?
Elektroneuromyografie? Also Herr Oberst,
ich bin mir nicht sicher für eine Details zu diesem Thema.
Ich werde es nach der Prüfung recherchieren.
Wenn Sie als dienomästischer Diagnose Neuropathie denken,
oder wenn der Patient Handgelenkschmerzen hat
und denken Sie auch auf Carpal-Tunnel-Syndrom,
würden Sie eine Elektroneuromyografie durchführen.
Können Sie Elektroneuromyografie, Herr Kollegen?
Leider nicht.
Bestimmen Sie in diesem Fall Harnsäure?
Ja, das ist auch wichtig.
Als Diagnose der Französischen kommt auch eine Artitis Eureka.
Deswegen sollen wir Harnsäurewerte bestimmen.
In diesem Fall führen Sie eine Dopplex-Sonographie durch?
Also die Patientin leidet unter
großsehe Schmerzen.
Also ja, wir sollen eine Dopplex-Sonographie durchführen,
um eine PVK auszuschließen.
Bei der PVK können wir auch Schmerzen in den Füßen feststellen.
Das wäre sinnvoll.
Können Sie uns eine Dopplex-Sonographie aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich werde Sie über Dopplex-Sonographie aufklären.
Dopplex-Sonographie ist eine spezielle Ultraschalluntersuchung.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns,
die durch Blutstörungen
Stenose
oder Thrombose genau zu erkennen.
Diese Untersuchung ist sowohl chemaisfrei als auch strahlenfrei.
Wir sollen vorher die zu untersuchende Körperregion
mit einem Gel einschmieren,
damit der Schallkopf fehlerfrei arbeitet.
Und die Ultraschallwelle
macht die Gefäße sichtbar.
Und wir können die Gefäße auf einem Monitor sehen.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. 20-30 Minuten.
Dafür benötigt der Patient keine spezielle Vorbereitung.
Es gibt keine Komplikationen oder Kontraindikationen.
Nach der Untersuchung gibt es keine Anverschränkungen.
Der Patient kann den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Okay, Herr Kollegen.
Ich habe keine Frage.
Gehen Sie auf unser Infodesk
und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifizierung.
Danke Ihnen, Herr Oberst. Sie sind sehr nett.